hi everyone welcome to tasty's cook with
color live i'm inca and i'm so excited
to be here if you've watched some of my
youtube videos you know that i love
making dishes inspired by color
you know color and food
great fun so today i'm making a brand
new dish inspired by tasty's colorful
cookware sets and it's going to be super
fun i have some special guests coming by
as well we're going to hang out you know
play games and have a little fun taste
test session at the end so definitely
you know just spend time with me stick
around i would also love to know where
you guys are from what's your name let's
introduce ourselves conrad
conrad hi
so excited i'm also so excited hi rose
hi james hi anne
thank you emmy squared i
heart you too
um
all right i'm i'm i'm so excited to to
be here today it's gonna be really fun
the dessert's gonna be i hope you guys
like it i don't know i think it's gonna
be really colorful um hi jesse from
toronto
hi amanda from arizona like the comments
are just like
we're
this is
oh once again if you're just joining us
i'm inka and this is cook with color
live today i'm going to be making a
special dish inspired by tasty's
colorful cookware set and we actually
asked you all to choose which set should
be inspiring my dish today so the
choices were actually
red and we're gonna have a graphic pop
up here so you can see it there you go
we have blue
pink rainbow
gray
or green
so there it is a bunch of different
colorful ones
and now it's time to reveal which ones
you guys picked we had a pole and all
and this is the one that won so you
ready drum roll please we have a team
here thank you everybody all right
and you chose rainbow
oh my gosh so many colors to play with
so thank you everybody this is tasty's
16-piece multi-color cookware set it has
everything from like you know skillets
to stockpots to little tiny ceramic bows
and even like a spatula and a spoon oh
also it has this like tasty recipe
booklet so it's just like everything you
need to get started in the kitchen you
can buy these online or in store at
walmart for 79 dollars so i think we're
going to drop a link in the comments
right for people to check out for you to
check out if you want um oh and then one
more thing about the dish today we also
asked you if you wanted it to be sweet
or savory and it was very very close but
you guys chose sweet which honestly i'm
very into because i love making desserts
so
that's what we'll be making today
all right
pluto's forever you want a pink set good
choice solid choice
virile star
rainbow is awesome
that is true rainbow is awesome and and
i hopefully you guys will see how we'll
be able to play with rainbow a little
bit today
um
should we start cooking okay all right i
think it's time we start cooking so i'm
going to grab one of these
pots here
and come on over and follow me to this
side
all right i'm just going to set this
right on here so one of my favorite
desserts to make are tarts and
especially fruit tarts just because you
know they're so
pretty and like present you know it's
like presentation wise it looks really
good it tastes really good so i thought
it'd be fun to make a rainbow custard
tart to make things really fun so let's
get into it the first thing we're going
to make is the
tart base and i have a couple of
ingredients here
top down shall we
oh okay
and today i'm using this blue non-stick
three quart saute pan from this set
which is currently over low heat and i'm
going to go ahead and add in this sugar
which is in my tiny little blue ceramic
bowl super cute and we're just going to
sprinkle the sugar all over
the pan
all right there you go
and then the idea here is we're not
trying to caramelize it we just want to
cook it until it's dissolved and
this might take some time but
i'm not going to stir it either
hmm
all right this is oh i should turn up
the heat a little bit
and then the reason you don't want to
stir it is because it might caramelize
so we're just going to let this sit for
a little bit
and camera hi everyone i wanted to see
you guys um you can also use butter
instead of sugar for the crust but sugar
makes for a sturdier crust that's why
we're gonna go with sugar today so now
i'm just gonna let this
heat up and
heather asks what you're cooking okay
heather what am i cooking today well
you'll see i guess you have to stick
around
so far you know it's a rainbow custard
tart
you know so that's what we'll be doing
and um
great okay so while this is slowly
dissolving
uh some of my friends actually sent in
color themed pop culture trivia
questions for me to answer so
let's try to figure these out together
i'm definitely gonna need your help so
if you know the answer drop them in the
comments
so
yeah all the support you have katie mike
are you are you ready for this yes are
you ready for the first question okay no
but yes yes okay we've got the first one
from your friend hannah
and uh here it is
okay what is the infamous mario kart
track that floats in space and has no
rails
i know this answer
because i play a lot of mario kart do
you guys play mario kart i get super
competitive but i believe this is
rainbow road which is one of the hardest
tracks
in mario kart
that was complete first one you got one
point here not that there's any points
really are you ready for the next one uh
yeah the next one comes from your friend
jasmine okay here it goes
in this film when a young girl comes of
age she inherits a special power that is
both a blessing
and a curse
gosh wait i feel like there's a lot of
films like this no
okay i'm going to need some help with
this one is it does that i'm assuming it
has to do with color
all of these do have to do with this
color guys please please please i don't
know help her in the comments help me
please pic pixar movie
it's a pixar movie
turning red
oh
what is that your guess that's my guess
final answer yes is turning red yeah
oh my god
you did it you did it no it's not that's
true you're okay don't stress hidden
river ninja got that right
all right are you ready for the next one
yes this one is from merle okay okay go
for it
okay in this movie will smith saves the
world from aliens
while wearing a suit
okay so will smith has saved the world
like multiple times
and i think i know what this is but i
think someone else beat me to
[Music]
nope okay well if nobody's guessing i'm
gonna guess it i say it's men in black
yeah
you got it too and hi
nice okay are you ready for your final
question
yes is your sugar okay i know i'm
distracting you oh my god thank you oh
my gosh okay no we're good
you guys i'm so bad at multitasking ah
okay all right is it dissolving it is
not dissolving yet so we're gonna
turn this up a little more
there you go okay okay final question
okay this is this one's the hardest one
just warning you you're gonna be great
though and the audience will help you
okay let's go for it
hi inga finish the lyrics to this 2019
harry styles hit song i don't want to be
alone
you're so
i only know watermelon sugar
color color you're so you're so golden
yeah golden it's golden
wait i know this oh my god okay let's go
then thank you oh my god emmy squared
thank you golden yeah that was the
hardest one and you did it oh my god
thank you
i did not know it was 2019 but now i
know
ugh
well that was our color theme trivia
round you did an excellent yeah four out
of four thank you nice job how is the
sugar the sugar is taking its time so
right now we have the heat up on
super high but you know what it's uh
it's still going it's still going maybe
you could share that fun color fact oh
yes i have a fun color fact so the fun
color fact i have is that did you know
that the color orange doesn't actually
come no
the color no
the color orange the word orange
is named after the fruit and not the
other way around this is what i'm trying
to say but like it like blows my mind so
much that i always get it mixed mixed up
so
orange is something that the europeans
didn't have a specific name for
the color right until the fruit orange
became popular so they named the color
orange after the fruit before that they
were calling the color orange yellow red
which makes sense but it's like a very
just like
long way to call orange but
blows my mind i did not know that
pretty face heather loves the honeycomb
background
me too it's nice
okay this is taking a while
oh you guys will just be here for a bit
um ink up maybe you can tell us like
what was one of the most challenging
food color challenges like 24 hour
challenges you've ever had to do oh okay
so
i don't know how many you guys have
washed but i've done like a bunch of
color food challenges right where i only
cook with one color for 24 hours and
one of my favorite ones that i did that
was also the most challenging ones was
clear foods for 24 hours where you're
only cooking with
ingredients that are clear which is
really hard to find and i i got to do
this in japan because i happened to be
there um
and it was just amazing learning about
so many different ingredients like from
vermicelli noodles to like just like
agar agar which is you know clear i even
found clear soy sauce which was
fascinating so it was very challenging
but because of that it was also the most
fun so yeah that's like one of my
favorites
all right we're just swirling still
kitty what do you think we should do
here
um you know maybe did you turn up the
heat a little bit more
it's on
highest hi wolfy love
gasper says shout out to the clear soy
sauce honestly yes shout out to the
clear soy sauce it was
it was how did they get it to be clear
the soy sauce i think there's like a
special way of processing the soy sauce
to take the color away it's like there's
also clear
cola for example did you know right
everyone's like what
i know so go watch that video oh it's
melting okay
all right all right friends
we are getting there slowly
slowly slowly slowly
i'm gonna move it a little bit to make
sure everything is you know sugar takes
patience i have cooked with sugar many
times
love it but it's tricky
and just you know you need a lot of
patience but we're doing good okay
okay
all right here's the part where i swirl
and it's just like
the the thing the most frustrating thing
is you can't stir it because
then it won't be good no more
so all right
okay
still swirling wolfberg you love the
indian food 24 hour challenge oh thank
you i had a lot of fun with that too oh
my god making that naan bread was
so hard but so rewarding
there was crystal pepsi in the 90s
hidden river ninja what oh wait yes
there was
side of potatoes 13. you love the
cookware
nice
all right this is getting closer
and i'm going to go ahead and add the
marshmallows right in here
now
all of them
ta-da
and i'm going to give this a good stir
until it's completely melted all of it
oh my god marshmallow accident
all right
and can you just remind the audience
what you're making right now oh yes and
for those of you who are just tuning in
i am making a
rainbow custard tart today
and um right now i'm in the phase of
making the tart base with a bunch of
marshmallow and sugar and what will soon
be
soon have sear uh have cereal in it guys
this is this is looking pretty goopy
nice nice nice
all right i'm gonna turn down the heat
now because it's
could honestly just eat it like this no
marshmallow fluff is so good okay
is there a reason you did sugar instead
of butter
yes this is
why
this is the reason i'm doing sugar
instead of butter is because you know i
want my tart crust to stay firm
sturdier and so the sugar will help with
that
nice
okay
how's that looking
pretty good are we ready to put in the
cereal
awesome okay all right
so now i'm going to add in the fruity
cereal
uh whoop give me a second
and we're just gonna add this all right
in here
all of it
rainbow colored fruity cereal and i'm
just going to really like kind of crush
it
in there
this is going to be a
kind of tough but
the idea is to get as much cereal as
possible it's okay if there's
some left in the pan
i'm just
collecting
rainbow cereal here heather asks what's
your favorite color gosh how about you
tell me what's your favorite color i've
always struggled i actually
i ch i feel like blue is my favorite
color but sometimes you know a good
green also really gets me going so i'd
love to know what your favorite color is
okay
i feel like we're getting a nice little
clump here
so i'm going to
actually transfer my cereal mixture into
this pre-greased
tart pan as you can see
food
food cam can you see that
nice okay so i'm going to carefully
transfer this over
can i use another spatula there you go
and we're just gonna
whoa okay
there you go we're getting a little bit
of a craziness going on here okay
and i'm just going to mush it down
honestly i think i might have to go in
here with my hands
anka would you say that you're like neat
and clean in the kitchen or like are you
kind of messy okay look i am normally
very neat and clean actually no i try to
be neat and clean in the kitchen but
sometimes chaos happens and you just
gotta do what you do you know
does this feel chaotic to you right this
is a little chaotic because we're doing
sugar and rainbow and uh
crunchy cereal you know
but it's okay we got it we're just gonna
just slowly mush it in you know
all right all right
getting that in there
the idea is just to spread it around
evenly
okay
okay
that is looking
pretty good i would say
all right
how's that look
do we like it did we think yeah do you
have any tips on how to make this
easier oh okay tips on how to make this
honestly just don't be
don't don't be afraid to just really go
in there and like push it firm you know
the marshmallow i think does give some
sort of resistance so
and it's okay if you crush the cereal
because that's part of
the fun of it and it's it will still
give you nice texture
and uh
look
and if people are just joining us what
are we doing today
oh yes all right so people who are just
joining thank you for joining i am
making a rainbow custard tart i have
just made the tart base with some
marshmallow sugar and fruity cereal this
is inspired by tasty's multi-color
cookware set which you can get both
in store and online in store at walmart
specifically um
so here we are okay i think that's
looking pretty good to me so
we are actually about to have a special
guest join in so i'm going to go ahead
and pop this in the fridge or actually
culinary is going to help me with this
thank you tiffany
and um i might wipe my hands a little
bit you know that grease
okay
all right come over here
this is my friend tucker surprise hello
oh what an honor and a privilege to be
here i'm so excited thank you i thank
you for being here i'm i'm super excited
to have you oh my gosh you haven't even
finished the tart and i already want to
go face deep in it that was so good okay
so i'll tell you why i'm here okay we
are going to play a fun game called
what's in the box color edition
and now i'm sure by the title sorry we
didn't have a back track to play that so
i made my own noise
uh so we have a bunch of different
products here that i chose that i will
put into this little box that you cannot
see and you will have to reach in
feel around a little bit guess what the
product is and also
what color it is whoa what color it is
whoa i know that's gonna be hard
to know you can do it okay you know i
chose specific products you can do it
okay i just gotta say like this game
terrifies me i don't like sticking my
hand to something where i don't know
what it is so
everything everything's okay you'll be
okay
nothing is deadly here
okay or is that okay no i'm kidding
nothing's deadly okay are you ready
no yes every we're safe you know what
okay ready ready close your eyes i'll
put the first one in
okay it is in feel free to reach in the
box whenever you feel comfortable
oh wow what is it
okay that was so fast
oh my goodness pepper but how am i
supposed to know whether it's red green
or yellow or orange you can't you can
always feel it on the texture of the
pepper
you do it you do it
oh i know the color actually
okay what color do you think okay you
know what i have i'll tell you i'll give
you a hint it's my favorite one i don't
know your favorite color not my favorite
color my favorite pepper
red
oh
my goodness score one for inga okay
close eyes again i promise you
everything is you'll be okay okay i just
want to say i did not look i swear i
didn't look before this
here we go okay
wait for it okay it's in the
is it squishy
[Music]
we'll see
oh okay what are we feeling oh yeah
sorry i should have warned you smooth
but it's aloe vera
we have a savant in the room what that
makes sense why you're hosting this live
i guess incredible okay so what color is
it green of course
look at that it's good for the skin
right i know i was like oh my gosh i
almost poked you with this okay here we
go we're on to the next one eyes closed
please how many do we have we have a few
more oh my god a few more okay
people we're figuring this out we're
we're figuring out
so i
what are you doing
okay great so i'm being told that there
okay so people i love that my brain
didn't go to you could just lift off the
box incredible i would hear i was
throwing things inside okay everything
is good
reach in the box
what have you done
oh my goodness what is it what could it
be
tortilla chips wow oh my gosh
is there more okay no that you got it
but what is the color
um you can feel it in the texture it
could be yellow it could be blue it
could be white
is it
can't fool her tracy said she yeah
that's right tracy you can't fool she
can't fool me but like i don't know if
it's blue or yellow oh my gosh guys you
know what that's my mom talking smack
right now
mom i'd like to see you drive 15 minutes
to the office right now
come on mom okay what's the color what's
the color i'm going to go with
yellow
you know what
you got you've got close enough
i should not have put that in my mouth
they're really crunchy though they're
delicious okay
okay
we're on to the next one people
eyes closed here we go
okay
what's in the box
oh my gosh there it is
yup didn't warn you again i'm so sorry
pomegranate seeds i mean
someone hired you for the well you
already have a busy corn but then i felt
the pit in the middle okay what's the
color obviously well
red
red clearly red
wow i love me some pomegranate seeds you
know
okay we have okay i believe
a couple more okay okay so here we go a
few more even oh they're going to be
coffee now you are literally crushing
this i'm shocked actually i'm not
shocked you're incredible here we go
what's in the box
it's my favorite line to say
no one's making me say it i'll just do
it over and over
what does it feel like
what's your favorite brownie
bubble is it brownie oh my goodness
it can't be full living my best best
life
and for bonus points what's the color of
the brownie chalk unless it's red
because we just talk about red chocolate
it's brown okay there we go i was trying
to trick you i was trying to trick you
could have been a blondie much like me
that's okay
here we go next up
we have
i got sidetracked sorry
i really enjoy the next product here we
go
what's in the box
[Music]
these feel like little turds
and maybe they are what color
no just kidding it's not don't worry
it's not a pickle is it it is a pickle
is it
oh my gosh is it pickle yeah but what
color pickle
green yeah oh my gosh
unbelievable i must say you really have
your colors down pat and i love the
pickle so much do you like a pickle no
it's quite the divisive food oh my gosh
oh my god here we go okay i just touched
it all over okay we have one more okay
ready
and while i'm putting this in i must say
that pretty face heather says inga is
her fave incredible and goes my fave too
we love you we left tucker too thanks
heather oh my gosh thank you okay
what's in the box i'm gonna have tears
in my eyes okay oh my god nope it's a
coconut
wow but what color it's brown and white
on the inside unbelievable
i'm sorry can i just explain what
happened i actually just inhaled the
pickle
and it really wow that thing almost shot
out we're good to go though okay well
you just absolutely crushed that thank
you well you know what i got i got one
for you no yes one for me yes a twist
okay i love that okay guys close your
eyes i want to look okay don't i'm not
looking
he's not gonna get this
i'm willing to bet i won't i don't think
i have the fingers that you do
tell me when okay dummy one okay here i
go come on come on can i open i forget
yes okay great
okay here we go
oh my god i went so quickly
oh baby
okay so instantly i'm thinking mashed
potatoes but that can't be it
okay
um
we're gonna really oh baby take tact
tape tap take okay oh boy it's like a
mashed potato but is it a dough is it a
cookie is it a dough is it the final
answer
mashed potato white
what is that
what is this
what is this it's mashed potato but it's
purple you know what i'll take it the
fact that i got mashed potato incredible
okay oh my goodness it's okay i'll eat
this thank you oh my god
oh what a pleasure to be here people
inga thank you so much for letting me
destroy your set this was incredible oh
my god oh my god the potato i know i'm
so sorry this was so fun and if you're
looking for more fun stick around
because there is more fun segments and
special guests coming thank you so much
thank you tucker
okay oh thank you so much all right okay
bye bye oh god sorry oh my god
you guys all right um bye tucker
tucker's cleaning his hand off camera so
we're gonna go back here everywhere oh
my gosh that was really fun whoa
whoa that was actually a lot more fun
than i thought it was gonna be i thought
i was going to be just terrified the
entire time but it turns out tucker was
the one who's terrified
okay so next we are going to make our
custard for the custard tart
and the approach i'm going to do today
it's not the traditional one it's kind
of like a one-pot method where we're
just going to do everything in here it's
kind of like a shortcut
and honestly it just tastes just as good
so that's what we're going to do and i'm
going to start by making the rainbow
pastry cream i'm using this red six
quart stock pot over here from the
cookware set which you can buy once
again in store walmart or online and
then it right in here without turning on
the heat i'm going to add in
my sugar
and my corn starch
all of that right in here and some salt
and then
i'm adding in some lemon zest because if
you watch my stuff i love adding lemon
zest and everything a bit of citrusy
flavor like a just a burst of something
nice to complement you know something
like vanilla something a little more
just like it brightens it up a little
which i really like so i'm just going to
go in here
and add a little bit of that
that's looking pretty good you guys
can't see what's in the pot can you
don't you have a lemon custard tart
recipe or is that an apple custard i
have both a lemon meringue tart recipe
and an apple tart recipe look i just
love tarts okay um but yes the
lemon meringue tarts i put so much lemon
in it it's so good okay so that's
looking pretty good
so i'm just gonna give this a little
whisk
over here
okay
and then uh let me just turn this
no heat and then over here in this pot
i'm going to
add in some egg yolks which is in this
cute little ceramic bowl you guys
there's eight egg yolks in this tiny
little
bowl
it's amazing i don't know how and is
that bowl in the set oh that bowl isn't
this sad thank you katie this bowl is in
the set okay so we're gonna pour in the
yolks right here
and i'm going to add in all of this milk
and just whisk it food cam you see this
just so you guys can
there you go okay
we're gonna add in all of it
and it's a little chaotic in here right
now give me a second okay
there's a lot of milk okay there's a lot
of milk so i'm gonna do my little
cleanup
right here and we're just gonna pour
that all in
all right
how's that looking okay
so
now
just like you know once you don't see
any yolk bits in here we're gonna go
ahead and add it back into
our other
pot
so
top down yeah okay so we're gonna all
add all of this in here
all that goodness and i'm also going to
add in
a butter
block
no holding back for this one just going
all in okay
i love that yellow ceramic bowl
oh yeah you see this yellow ceramic bowl
i honestly i love using little bowls
like this because you know it's great
for measuring out ingredients like even
just now you saw that we put like the
salt the egg yolks and the butter in
them so
measuring things out is really nice when
you're making desserts like this and so
and especially when it comes out in
different sizes you just know how much
how much you put in each one so yep
okay i'm going to crank the heat up to
medium right now and i'm just going to
bring this to a boil because we want to
get that you know like custard has like
a thicker texture so
that's what i'm trying to go for here
and we're just going to
continuously whisk this until it
thickens and
while we're waiting for this
katie my producer behind the camera is
actually going to give me a quiz to find
out what color matches my personality
are you
have you ever taken a quiz like this
before i have surprisingly not taken a
quiz language before oh wow okay well i
feel like we're going to learn a lot
about you right now yeah yeah you're
going to need people oh hi people are
saying hi to me in the comments hello
hello hi hi homie princess this is the
slightest kitchen i've ever seen wow
thank you thank you yeah
it's the team here i cannot take credit
but i'm glad you like it um okay if you
want to turn up the heat a little bit
like go for it i know we had some heat
issues before okay great so are you
ready for this quiz
okay we're going to get really deep into
your psyche here oh okay okay you're
going to say i'm going to say a
statement you're going to say if you
strongly disagree or strongly agree or
you could be like kind of neutral okay
okay
i enjoy traveling and or trying new
things strongly agree oh great great i
almost mark strongly disagree sorry i
got it right okay
my mood is easily affected by the moods
of people around me
agree oh so
how so if someone's like like yeah i
feel like it's some if somebody's sad
like it's also kind of weird for me to
be happy when somebody said you know
it's like and if somebody's happy i
think it's infectious so and if
somebody's angry i'll probably be mad
too
okay
love it okay
i like spending time with people but i
prefer to work alone
oh that's hard
you know i can't say that i'm in a room
full of like people that i'm literally
working with right now so i feel like i
should say what was the thing
you like spending time with people but
you prefer to work neutral neutral
interesting interesting okay
um the next one i enjoy activities that
involve performances such as sports
acting or singing
oh hmm i'm gonna say agree agreed you so
you like oh perfect so you like sports
and acting and singing
i like karaoke
wait what do you think
um oh there's like so many good ones i
don't know i love singing disney songs
oh
you know so
it's a great one um people should leave
in the comments what's their favorite
karaoke song to sing favorite okay part
of your world
little mermaid oh it's so good or you
know um there's reflection if you're
just like really angry just saying like
let it go you know it's like let it go
you know all the disney classics
all right are you ready for the next one
yes okay i tend to follow my heart
instead of my brain
do i follow my heart do i follow my
brain
usually i follow my stomach let's be
honest
unfortunately that's not an option
it should be though i'm going to say
neutral neutral okay and also you're
getting asked what are you making right
now what am i making okay for people who
don't know what i'm doing right now i'm
making the custard for this rainbow
custard tart that we'll be making um
inspired by
tasty multi-color cookware at the back
um i'm just making the custard and
katie's asking me questions katie's my
producer behind the camera um i'm being
assessed about my personality which will
then tell me what color i am apparently
so well we're very we're getting very
close okay okay the next one is i need
to stay organized or my day will slip
away
so
like i need it but do i do it you know
um
i'm going to say agree agree okay okay
got it because your heads can get like
stuck in the clouds
okay i often feel motivated by pressure
or competition especially when it
involves my skills and passions oh man
i strongly agree agree strongly agreed
that was easy for you you knew
you were like i am this is like when we
do like competition frames like
competition cooking things on like tasty
or like buzzfeed
those are like i'm like i'm ready i'm
ready to win
okay well we're getting very close i
often get lost in daydreams
oh egg
neutral neutral neutral okay it happens
sometimes
somebody's asking what flavor is the
custard i like skye
um
the custard is well we're going to be
adding vanilla extract which i haven't
added yet but it's going to be vanilla
and a little bit of lemon zest so
hopefully a little bit of lemony vanilla
situation
and abigail is guessing they're going to
be the color blue we're getting very
close we actually only have one more
question somebody's guessing what color
yeah i'm ready maybe people should guess
right now because we're very close okay
you guys tell me your guesses what color
do you think i am
last one
i am always early or on time because
being late stresses me out
agree
agree okay what like because it really
gets to you when you're late
i don't like being late i don't like it
i yeah i'm the same way five minutes
you're on time like traffic when i'm
stuck in traffic oh
it hurts okay are you ready to find out
okay people are saying you're pink blue
green light purple oh very specific
yellow or green okay
lavender yellow five sweet caroline okay
yellow and blue someone says you're both
okay are you ready to find out i'm ready
you're red
wow
you are fearless especially when it
comes to decorating though you spend a
lot of time out of the house you love
having people over whether it's for wild
parties or epic movie nights okay hold
on why parties
yeah that's what it is that's who you
are you're kendra
okay i'm red you guys i'm ready i'm
gonna be very aggressively good at
decorating later
um and that was the personality quest
oh my god abigail says what she's not a
red i agree with you
what color do you think well i guess you
guys already told me what color you
think i am but
ah sweet carolina shooketh
red is scary she's not scary oh but what
if i i'm kidding
how's the custard the custard is slowly
going
i feel like our heat is a little low on
here we would cook it on a stovetop but
we wanted you guys to see so we're using
this right now
um yeah it's uh slowly going
what do we think
[Laughter]
oh fun color fact yes i do have another
fun color fact which actually has to do
about chocolate so
did you know what the original color of
chocolate was do like tell me or tell me
tell me your guess is in the comments
below it's not brown
but can you guess what color it was
is anybody answering
oh
not brown not brown don't guess brown
green oh actually there are green
chocolates white
clear
actually the color of chocolate
originally was
red which is apparently my personality
color
and the reason it's red is because back
in the 1800s
chemist actually manipulated
chocolate and in order to take out the
bitterness right and in doing that
process they turned the chocolate from a
deep red to
what we know of it now as a brown isn't
it crazy
we have red chocolate and we have yellow
red color instead of orange
oh it's okay i see i can feel it coming
together now a little bit a little bit
slowly
actually
and it smells good i smell the lemon
this is the best part
foodie issa
oh nine got that answer right
you got it right you got red how do you
do that
i had no idea when i found out i was
just
like
shocked
there's a chip left over my chip i'm
sorry
i can't believe i got the chip wrong
i got so close so what advice would you
give to like home chefs if they're
making desserts or custard like things
that you follow hmm i think when it
comes to making you know the question
was just
tips to making desserts i think
always
if it depends i think on like where you
are making if you're trying a recipe for
the first time definitely read through
the recipe first and don't deviate from
it too much you also have to be very
careful and watch
like keep an eye on what you're doing
right like for example this custard the
reason i'm stirring continuously is if i
don't do it there might be some parts
that are overcooked and the at the at
the bottom it could be the egg it could
be in this case the the starch and
that's why i have to continuously stir
it and i have to watch it because you
know you can see right now it's already
thicker
food cam i don't know if you can see or
top down maybe if you guys can't see the
food cam situation right now
it's getting thick yeah yeah you can see
that it's getting thicker and the thing
is this process happens so fast that
like you can think like oh it's taking
forever but then once you walk away you
come back and you you get this so
definitely just be patient
don't try to rush things and you'll get
there
have you ever had like a major disaster
making uh
have i ever had a major of course i've
had major disasters with how much i cook
cooking is not a not a perfect thing all
the time you know i think a lot of times
in media people make you think that oh
it's always like on point no i think you
always mess up sometimes you know miss a
step sometimes you
at once time i miss
one time i used salt instead of sugar oh
my god that was so sad but you know it's
just little things like that and this is
looking pretty good
and we're almost there
so i'm just gonna keep doing this
is the custard recipe already on tasty
yes it is we're actually going to talk
about that in the set in a second but
it's actually already on the tasty app i
believe you can search inka's rainbow
custard tart so i mean honestly if you
have the ingredients you can follow
along right now i'd be thrilled if you
did that but um
okay i think this is looking pretty good
so i'm going to turn off the heat
okay see you oh theo you've been
watching our videos for years
thank you theo
abigail asks oh abigail yes my arms are
hurting lol yes
i've literally been doing this for how
long i don't even know i don't want to
know
too long too long too long okay the heat
is now off so i'm going to add in my
vanilla extract
and we're just going to stir that in
great i'm gonna put this down here
and oh you can smell the vanilla
or i wish you guys could smell it i can
smell it fosho
okay
all right i'm bringing my bowl in
and food cam
hey
okay
so i'm gonna put this whisk away
and just gonna go ahead and pour all of
this pour all of this right through
here
to a strainer
all right
and
because i don't have enough hands i'm
gonna put this in here
and just push it through
and the reason i'm doing this is because
i just want to make sure the custard is
as smooth as possible and this helps
with that
process so okay
this is now looking
pretty good we have a nice little
goopy texture you see that jiggly oh
yeah okay
great all right so now
because we have to move some things off
the table i'm going to step back and a
culinary is going to step in to help me
switch this up a little bit
thank you thank you team
can't do it without them you know
okay
thank you
all right i'm gonna move these move my
pastry cream aside
and bring in my bowls
so we're gonna do six colors today i
know there's seven colors in the rainbow
but we're gonna do six um
and
divide it up into six bowls
top down please so people can see
[Music]
no okay i was like
all right
sassy underscore cass what are we making
today
we're making rainbow custard tart and
you're you're just tuning in into the
best part because i'm about to scoop
this and divide this into
six different bowls and we're gonna
color them
so i'm gonna oops
food cam you can't see sorry okay
just gonna
add these in here
so what got you interested in like
colorful foods
oh so the reason i was really interested
in color food was because
you know i think natural food coloring
no just like in you know in this world
there's like so many different kinds of
ingredients that have naturally
different colored
different colors naturally different
colors and i love being able to
experiment with different ingredients
so i just kind of want to push the
limits a little bit and experiment with
different things and i think there's
it's so much fun to like you know
play with the colors a little bit you
know what dish when you people say you
eat with your eyes and it's like when
you look at it and it's super visual
kind of just gives you a lot of joy so
that's why i really like doing it you
know
sounds a little cheesier normal but it's
true
okay so
divided my custard so now we're going to
go ahead and
play with the colors so
six colors here and uh what we have
actually i have five four colors here um
we're just gonna mix it up a little
these are natural
coloring uh natural food coloring
they're made with natural vegetable
juices and spices
so
we're gonna play with these so we're
gonna go with red first
i guess you guys don't okay
okay how many drops are you doing for
each i'm testing it out right now it's
like 10 drops for the red and i'm gonna
try and do
four five six seven eight nine ten
like
maybe a little bit more yellow than the
red here
you know it's just just as you go
and then yellow i mean the custard is
already a little bit yellow so
hopefully okay
then we're gonna add the green in this
one
12
drops
okay
blue in this one
[Music]
whoa that was a big one
sorry
okay
and then we're gonna do purple which is
this is like very basic sort of like
what plus what equals what color
blue plus red equals purple
pretty face heather is going to a
cooking class tomorrow and is so nervous
oh my gosh that's so exciting
i love it when people explore you know
like new things
i hope it's fun i'd love to know what
you're making
oh also once again if you're just
joining us eye makeup is a cook with
color live and i'm making a rainbow
custard tart that's inspired by
tasty's multi-color cookware set and i'm
right now i'm just making the different
colored custard here
i think i
got a little too excited with the
coloring my mom has just chimed into the
chat and she wants to know what food
coloring did you use
katie hi katie's mommy
great um we are
we are using natural food coloring which
again is made with um
like different colored vegetables and
spices so i'm assuming like yellow like
turmeric maybe green is like spirulina
or you know oh i'm adding more color
nope um matcha
you know and then blue is like you know
butterfly pea
um
there's so much that like red could be
beets you know there's just so many
things to play with
and i have a different whisk for
every color here
hey
all right
looking pretty good right the colors
yeah definitely oh this is this purple's
real nice look at it that's purple can
you see it hi hi
look
wow
kind of into it hi autumn waters 116.
abigail asks what's your zodiac sign oh
i don't know oh my i know my zodiac sign
i'm talking about i'm a gemini
but i don't know very much about that
side of things so if you have any things
that you think
i need to know please tell me
okay
look at that
we have six different colors
i mean this looks a little more like
pinkish red but we have red orange
yellow green blue purple now we're gonna
let them cool in the fridge and then
transfer them to piping bags but with a
little bit of movie magic and a
fantastic culinary team we actually have
that done already so we're gonna swap
these out because of you know timing
thank you team thank you team
and i'm just gonna clean this up a
little bit
whoa
top down food cam what's better i want
you guys to see
oh okay double double camera there you
go now we have six different colors
they're beautiful they're kind of like
pastel-ish i love it
i'm gonna bring my tartan right here
this has also been chilling in the
fridge a little bit so
now for the fun part we are going to be
piping the custard onto our crust
um starting with red orange yellow green
blue purple okay we ready to do this
let's do it
when the audience picked uh rainbow were
you a little nervous are you excited oh
when i was very nervous when you guys
picked rainbow because i wanted to
utilize like so many different fruits i
was like enough fruit well fruits and
just different colors right rainbows a
lot of colors but i think it would
actually turn out to be really really
fun challenging is scary but fun
all right i'm gonna go
in with the red here
all right
and i'm going to actually smooth it out
with a spatula here
you know just to make sure it looks good
and the reason we're doing it with each
step is because we don't want the colors
to all smudge
together so we're going one by one hi
micah from the uk
oh heather you're making monkey bread
whoo that is exciting
bread is a whole nother level of
you know cooking that's like
pretty intense but i'm so proud of you
for going
and doing that
okay i'm going to spread
maybe a little bit more of the orange
here i think
okay
would you say you're a perfectionist
when it comes to
making i mean i feel like you do a lot
of like baked goods and they're very
beautiful oh thank you thank you katie
that's so nice um i would say i am a
little bit of a perfection when it comes
to making desserts or just like i think
plating is such an important part of any
dish
of course it has to taste good but once
again i feel like whether you're cooking
for other people or cooking for yourself
there's a delight in you know having
something that just looks really nice
really beautiful to enjoy
and um but yes i would say especially
when i'm making it for someone making it
for friends
i want them to to love it the moment
they see it so
i like really just taking my time with
them
um
oh this one's a nice one look at this
green oh yeah
okay
all right
green is going in
and i'm just cleaning this so this is a
little tip that's uh that you should
know just
wiping the spatula clean with every time
you smooth it out once again to make
sure the colors don't
all clump together
i also like doing it when i'm slicing
cake to make sure i get clean slices
um then we have blue
right there
all right
it's looking good this is a really nice
blue color
trusted red says oh my gosh
thank you thank you i can't i can't read
that comment i feel very embarrassed um
but hi simon
um
okay last thing is purple
jaden this is not a pie this is a tart
what is the difference between a pie and
a tart all right kitty help me out with
this
no because i actually looked this up
like tart is like i think the crust is
also different and there's no with tart
you don't really have like an
upper layer right like an upper crust
whereas thai a pie you usually have it
so so is tart just an open pie
so i feel like someone said that before
i wasn't sure someone cool probably some
way cool
okay look at this uh rainbow it's hard
it's coming together
top down please or where you oh actually
food cam looks better
tada
wow this is actually really nice i
really like the pastel colors karina
says this looks so good thank you karina
i'm so excited okay at this point we
would put this in the fridge or i would
normally put it in the fridge to set for
at least like an hour or overnight
because right now it's like extremely
jiggly and we want it to firm up but
once again we've got some movie magic
and the culinary team has
been an incredible help
and we have one that's already made look
at that
wow
you guys the colors are incredible
thank you team thank you culinary team
woof chili
[Applause]
oh my gosh it's so pretty
i'm going to take these
piping bags out for now
and um
okay so
this looks pretty good right now but
and we're going to have a special guest
come in and taste this but the last
thing i'm going to do
because you know once again i like to
jazz things up a little bit i want to
add more decoration in there
and i thought what better way to do it
than
with fruit you know so
i'm gonna go ahead and
do that bringing in my food i'm gonna
put some gloves on because we've been
touching a lot of things
but um
i like working with food a lot like
especially in dishes because
they just naturally have so much color
they also add so much flavor especially
in desserts so
today this rainbow custard tart gives me
the perfect excuse to just go crazy and
just experiment with as many fruit as i
want
so over here
i don't know what's easier maybe top
down
you guys can see sort of what fruit i
have i have kiwi
mango
pineapple
dragon fruit and i actually already have
some strawberries and cherries cut up
and
oh and also i have blueberries and
blackberries as well but over here as
you can see that i also have these
cookie cutters
um flower shaped ones heart shaped ones
star more flower shaped ones
and um
this is
once again it's just about you know
presentation we're gonna have fun with
it and i'm thinking for mango we could
do stars because you know it's orange
shaped orange color and a be a nice
shape for that
what's your favorite fruit
my favorite fruit is i love strawberries
for sure i also love mango
i also love this is a bit controversial
i love durian
which i know not everybody loves what
does durian taste like and i know it has
a distinct smell yes
it
durian tastes to me like it has a very
tropical flavor to me but in a way that
is different from like mango you know um
and it
i guess like the
the smell of it
it's crazy because the smell of it to me
is so good but then to so many people
they're like what um did you know that
they just invented or they just came out
with a durian that has no
that takes away the strong smell
yeah i just saw the news the other day
and it's breaking news breaking breaking
news no smell this should also be a new
show where you give us food news
i'm ready i'm ready okay kiwi going in
there just
right in there there you go oh yeah
just beautiful shapes beautiful shapes
so do you give food as gifts i feel like
that's something
some people do they make stuff and they
give it as a gift to people oh 100 i
feel like i
love i make so much food at home and i
don't actually have enough stomach to
eat
all of it
but also you know
once again sounds kind of cheesy but i
feel like it's true for a lot of people
who love cooking or baking you know it's
when you see how much how much people
enjoy your cooking that it makes you
want to cook even more you know and
i think for me too it just allows me it
gives me even more reason to just really
go out there and experiment with
different dishes and you know
take time with it kathy you love these
cookie cutters me too they're making
this so they make it so much easier it's
like very um
low effort high reward you know instead
of cutting it out slowly you can just
poop that was my mother i guess she
wants these cookies
i guess i need a cupcake i think you
need to buy buy these cookie cutters for
your mom
okay
we don't need too much of each of these
because we only have very little surface
area
but just in case
okay we're moving on to the last one
here i'm cutting
hearts out of this dragon fruit
i have a dragon fruit fun fact actually
um did you know that dragon fruit do we
have a we don't have a whole dragon
fruit
dragon fruit all right because you know
like this is like this is red dragon
fruit by the way not white dragon fruit
um
dragon fruit they're named for their
bright pink like skin on the outside the
spiky skin with green scales and um
some believe it's because the pinks the
pink spikes
um the pink well the pink skin it
resembles
fire and then the green scales are kind
of like you know like dragon skin hence
dragon fruit which i think is like a
crazy
crazy interesting fact because
if i was a fruit i would want to be
dragon fruit um
that's a good question if you wear any
fruit
would you be dragon fruit dragon fruit
okay so i have some of these cut up
right now
so i'm gonna bring the custard tart back
here and i'm gonna go ahead and place
the fruit on
the very top okay
well
for you guys to see
what camera is that oh okay there you go
bill's behind the camera here and he
knows he just knows
okay so i'm thinking we could do like a
moon crescent shape
so i'm just going to go in here in the
beginning with
the strawberries and cherries we're just
going to lay that on here
it doesn't have to be super
you know this is my favorite part i'm
like nerding out over here but i truly
love this part of just like decorating
and having fun
with it
so are you coordinating the fruit with
the color i am coordinating the fruit
with the color yes red first for
cherries and strawberries and then next
up we're gonna do
stars for the mangoes
and the orange
and we're just laying it on there
like so
all right
it's kind of pretty you know
it looks really nice the shapes kind of
remind me of rainbow road from our car
yes it does look like a rainbow road
i should at mario kart
all right
this is
tilting there you go
is that a better look for you yeah
okay so now we're gonna go with the
yellow
pineapple
this is why i love fruit just look at
how many things you can do with this
nobody nobody saw that this is live but
you know
this is why i wear gloves
hey hey don't laugh at me
okay look i just got a little excited
okay geez
okay um i think that's good for yellow
and then we're gonna go with green kiwi
you guys this is why i can't get too
excited about things jayden says you'd
be a bit tell me why you're
a banana
what yeah what fruit would everyone be
if you were
katie where would you be i don't know
what fruit but one time really came over
to me and she was like you remind me of
bok choy
whoa
[Laughter]
we were like all naming what vegetable
or fruit we would be and they're like
you're bok choy and you're like what
what does that mean i think it's like
fun and spunky oh okay i'm like
to me that's like
sustenance yeah okay great
okay blue for berries bok choy is very
versatile yeah and it is a cute it's a
cute plant yes it's a cute plant it's
good there's mini bok choy there's a big
bok choy that would definitely be minnie
boy
mimi says dragon fruit no mimi said
passion fruit
and then xtfqi says dragon fruit okay
okay i see
i see you
passion food is so good oh my gosh i
love passion fruit
okay
and then now lastly we have purple
j rice is rambus is that only rum baton
spiky and scary on the outside sweet on
the inside because that's that's dope
okay
oh yeah dragon fruit and blackberry
with the little little hearts guys this
is looking
so good
can you see it
yeah you can because you're on food cam
okay
oh
my gosh
hey hey
maybe a little bit more no maybe a
little heart no wait what should i do
what should i do okay there you go
what do you think
do we like it yay
looking pretty good ooh cindy's a
strawberry chloe says pink
pink pineapple you fancy pink pineapple
i like that too okay
all right guys i think we are
here finished um
pretty happy with how it turned out
actually
thank you thank you okay i think now
it's time to get our taste tester
in here to give this a taste please
welcome my friend elise
hi
hello hi hi hi thanks for coming this is
insane wow thank you so this came about
because the audience today um they chose
rainbow and um
which is very much a rainbow i know and
it's inspired by can you tell that it's
inspired by the multi color cookware set
right here i can tell yes and then they
also wanted it to be sweet so i made a
rainbow custard tart with like fruits
coordinated to the color oh wow
this is spectacular like you got the
fruit it's healthy
the custard is made out of eggs i'm
assuming uh yes eggs and milk and a
bunch of other stuff eggs are my
favorite food did you know that oh
absolutely and then you got this
colorful cereal here fruity pebbles
right fruity cereal fruity cereal fruity
cereal
amazing okay so it's going to be very
fruity yeah i'm sure you like fruity oh
i love fruity okay all right so
i'm excited for you to try it i'm also
excited to to eat this because just
tarts are great oh thank you thank you
tiffany all right i'm going to try to
cut a slice here for you
and uh
this is going to be
i believe in you you've done this before
you don't believe in me i did this yeah
i did this before but like i do this on
camera where i can cut out the parts
where it work let's go okay all right
let's try to just like um should i try
to cut it like this this i feel like we
want to get a little bit of the fruit
yeah right okay so yeah
oh should i hold this i'm scared for you
there's one okay that was easy
no one more time
all right
here you go
can you see that my hands are shaking
i can't
and i think
you know it happens to the best of us
hey hey okay careful
we're gonna do this
for you
i'm so excited it just has to look good
for you it doesn't have to look good for
me
wow i did it that was true skill there
thank you here you go so much for you
and i'm going to cut one for me now
do you see this
yeah it's so cute i know it's so pretty
blackberries it'd be this would look
really cool too if we had like the fruit
coloring the like covering the entire
strip too right like food all over next
time next time okay mine mine can just
look look like a little
of course little mountain give me the
pretty one this is natural this is what
i do at home okay
taste test taste cheers cheers please
cheers play cheers boop okay
let's try it here we go
oh
yes yes
it's a yes it's just like it's like a
melted ice cream almost like the texture
like the custard yeah
it's like kind of like a pudding
texture yeah and then all the flavors
mixed together and i like that it's
different textures we got some crunchy
creamy
chewy
i know that the marshmallow and the the
marshmallow
i am a fan i didn't delicious
thank you
thank you thank you elise thank you all
so much for watching thank you to my
team i so much fun hanging out and
cooking and once again if you want to
make this recipe you can find it on the
tasty app under inca's rainbow custard
tart
also be sure to check out once again
tasty's
colorful cookware online or in store
exclusively at walmart and bring tasty
home with you it's 79 right now and i
think katie's going to drop the link in
the comments below so
you can check it out if you want to
there's a graphic somewhere here
maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe
yeah we got it we got the graphic okay
great
one last thing before you guys leave if
you want to see me cook with color
some more i'm actually going to be
having a new show coming soon on tasty's
youtube channel called cooking with
color it's going to be me cooking with
color palettes inspired by some of my
favorite movies so it's gonna be pop
culture and color i hope you guys like
it otherwise thanks for watching thank
you for being here with me and i will
see you next time
bye
thank you